let's roll people let's go take two
Florencia Martin has brought back
history in a way that has made it so
alive
you're gonna find a Los Angeles that you
can taste and smell and touch because of
her world
in discussions with Damian about how he
wanted the film to look visually from
the get-go he said I want to be very
historically accurate
my first evolution is diving into
research and looking at what the city
looked like in the 20s
Florencia had this insane challenge with
this movie of not just recreating Los
Angeles at this time but also within
that recreating each Studio experience
within that recreating each of the sort
of fictional movie sets you're talking
about sets within sets within sets
the first week of shooting was the sort
of big kinoscope sequence we found this
location in pyru and we came here
because it's completely desolate and it
was what Hollywood and Studios looked
like in the silent film era auction what
had been a completely empty field
florenceia and her team used as the
basis for building outdoor silent movie
studio with six or seven sets running at
all times it was extraordinary okay
so now what did we discuss when in doubt
say something French there's two worlds
in this film there's people that are
very impoverished and then there's
people that have a lot of money looking
at how we were going to shape those
Worlds by color was really important
Damien wanted to be bold with our color
choices blessed of being historically
accurate
building sound stages an entire 900
person Battlefield and six high-end
homes and doing historical Recreations
Babylon is at the scale of these
mythical movies you heard of in the past
we've gotta innovate we've gotta Inspire
what happens up on that screen means
something
[Applause]